may is mental health month and
cinemasins is honored and excited to
partner again with Mental Health America
we're here to raise awareness of mental
health issues but raise a little money -
we got two spankin new cinemasins
t-shirts in the shop then we're going to
donate the profits of every sale to
Mental Health America if you want to
learn more about mental health check out
their website Mental Health America
dotnet this year's theme is for mind for
body and connection between physical and
mental health you can find information
on how animal companions social
connections and even humor can boost
your mental health and general wellness
for real we're real big fans of humor
here at cinemasins and laughter actually
makes levels of stress hormones decrease
which can relieve anxiety and improve
your mood mental health conditions are
real common and treatable we can help
reduce the burden of mental illness by
identifying symptoms and warning signs
early so check out these resources
Mental Health Month works not just
because it's about what others can do
for us but what we can do for ourselves
[Music]